we'd like to wish you a very Merry
Christmas and give you a brief rundown
of our holiday hours the regular service
center will close midday on Friday the
22nd of December and reopen on Wednesday
3rd of January our libraries and other
service centers will be closed on the
public holidays but will be open on some
of the days in between check our website
for teams we're back to normal from
Wednesday the 3rd of January if your
collection day falls on Christmas Day in
New Year's Day your bins will instead be
collected the following Saturday and our
transfer stations will be closed on
Christmas Day Boxing Day and New Year's
Day our sign poles are open every day
extinct for Christmas Day please check
our website for more information as
always for noise or dog control or
urgent after our calls you can contact
our answering service
Oh eight hundred nine six five four six
eight and follow the recorded
instructions from everybody in the why
malady District Council you wish you a
very Merry Christmas and a Happy New
Year
[Music]
you